[Applause]
taliban insurgents are rapidly making
ground in afghanistan
thousands have died and hundreds of
thousands more are homeless
so what happens now
the taliban believes in an extreme
version of islamic law when the group
was in power in afghanistan between 1996
and 2001
girls education beyond the age of 10 was
outlawed
public executions were common as were
stonings
television was banned and religious
dress codes were strictly enforced
after u.s troops arrived in 2001 in
response to the 911 terror attacks and
the taliban was ousted rules were
relaxed the number of girls in education
went up from 9 000 in 1999 to three and
a half million today
we have a lot of gain and achievement uh
we have women in different parts of of
the society women politicians women
economists women and health services and
everywhere
but now u.s british and other nato
troops have withdrawn from the country
afghan leaders
have to come together
we lost
thousands of american personnel
they've got to fight for themselves
and the taliban's influence has grown
once again
women are already seeing their freedoms
curbed and human rights violations are
on the rise
um
[Music]
the uk un and us say that they won't
recognize the taliban as a legitimate
government if it arrives by force we
will not accept a military takeover of
afghanistan
or return of the taliban's islamic
emirate
but the chinese government has already
held some talks with the group afraid
and russia has traditionally shown an
interest in the country so could be
another ally
in fact russia was the first country to
publicly engage with the taliban after
u.s troops withdrew early this year
the kremlin wants to protect its borders
from islamic extremism by allying with
the taliban against al-qaeda an islamic
state
iran's ties with the taliban also seem
to be growing
back in january senior officials in
tehran received a taliban delegation to
discuss relations between the two
countries
and india which has previously refused
to open communication channels with the
group has now confirmed it has been
talking to taliban officials
nearly half of the afghan population
currently requires humanitarian
assistance according to the world health
organization including 3.1 million
children
the world health organization said it is
struggling to get supplies in and
medical centers have been attacked by
the taliban
shipments of coveted vaccines through
the kovac scheme are still being
delivered the taliban says that it
supports the government's immunization
drive and officials hope that taliban
soldiers will leave vaccination centers
unharmed
the taliban themselves however brutal
have never been a threat outside of
afghanistan but under their previous
rule al-qaeda was free to plan the 9 11
attacks from inside the country they
gave safe harbor to osama bin laden
as part of the peace deal negotiated
with president trump last year the
taliban said it wouldn't allow terrorist
groups to shelter in the country
but if it does take power it's likely
that that promise will be broken
and so as the taliban's control over
afghanistan grows the stakes for the
country and the world
are high